okay so at the end of the last section I
cancelled our party and said that we
have this algorithm that works really
well in practice on theoretical spectrum
but the issue is going to be that when
we move to experimental spectra we're
going to have issues because these
experimental spectra often produce
errors here are a theoretical D
theoretical and an experimental spectrum
for the peptide nqe l so the theoretical
spectrum is on the top and then we're
giving you a hypothetical experimental
spectrum for this same peptide this
experimental spectrum highlights a
couple of different ways that the
experimental spectrum can be flawed so
it can it can detect false masses so
these are masses that are present in the
experimental spectrum but that don't
correspond to real masses in the
theoretical spectrum so examples are 99
and 299 here we also have missing masses
so their masses that are in the
theoretical spectrum of the correct
peptide but that don't actually get
produced in the experimental spectrum so
they're missing this is a problem
because our current implementation in
order for it to consider a peptide
correct the peptides theoretical
spectrum has to exactly match the
experimental spectrum that we have and
that's clearly not the case here so the
question then is what do we do and what
we're going to do is instead of having
to match the spectrum exactly we're
going to instead score a peptide based
off of how similar it is to the
experimental spectrum so for example
here right the theoretical spectrum of
nql is still pretty similar to the
experimental spectrum that we have
notice that it shares eleven masses so
we're going to say that the score then
of nql with this experimental spectrum
is equal to eleven so we need to use
this scoring function to say certain
peptides are better than others and to
use this to modify the branch-and-bound
algorithm that we have in order to make
it a little bit better so the idea the
that I want to use here is similar to
something called a cut in a golf
tournament now I'm a huge golf fan so
maybe I'm just partial to this idea but
I thought it fit it pretty well
so what the cut does is it reduces the
field to only the players that are
deemed to be in contention for the
tournament so if there are players that
are not doing too well after a couple of
rounds then they say okay well we're
just going to let them go home and we
want to have the tournament only for the
players who have a chance at actually
winning the tournament so here's a
hypothetical leaderboard and we may say
in this hypothetical small tournament we
want to keep the top three players on
the leaderboard so keeping in mind that
golf blow golf scores are good we put
the cut line here all right but this
would be unfair to this golfer right
because they're tied with the
third-place golfer and so we need to say
well we keep the top three players as
well as ties right so we keep the top
three players with ties and so this is
going to motivate on the bound step that
we do so after this step this cut where
we have four players reigning so the new
idea is we're going to call it
leaderboard cyclic peptide sequencing
and so how it works is that we're going
to start off with a zero peptide so this
is a empty string essentially and then
we're going to extend each peptide on
the leaderboard in each of 18 possible
different directions so we add each of
the 18 different amino acid masses to
the peptides that we have currently in
the leaderboard which when we begin is
empty or it has just the zero peptide
and then we're going to have a step this
cut step which is the new bound step and
it's going to cut the low scoring
peptide so it says assign everything a
score right see what the score of every
peptide is and then cut the low scoring
ones get them out of there so that we
can so that we can prevent the number of
solutions that we consider growing and
so that we can keep only the high
scoring peptides so we're going to keep
the top and peptides with ties then the
next step is going to say okay we'll
update this leader peptide right we're
going to keep keep a track of who the
what the leader peptide it should be and
if there is a higher scoring peptide
that we can find on the leader board so
if something moves up and becomes a
higher scoring peptide and it's mass is
equal to that parent mass that we can
detect by the parent mass I mean we said
that we're always going to be
able to reconnect mass of the entire
peptide should be so we always want to
check if these candidate solutions that
we have has a mass that's equal to that
total mass and then we're going to
eliminate any peptides whose mass is
going to grow too big so if the if their
mass exceeds the parent mass then we're
not going to want to expand them anymore
because their mass is too big and we
want to get rid of them too so once we
do these steps we're just going to
iterate these steps over and over again
so we have a branch step and then a
bound step and then we have an update
step where we say is there a leader and
can we get rid of anything whose mass
has gotten too big and so at the end
after we go through this procedure we're
going to branch and bound and branch and
bound it's actually going to guarantee
to always have an empty leader board at
the end so that's at step six after we
go through these steps two through five
we're going to have an empty leader
board and then at that time we return
what is our leader what's the best
peptide that we've encountered so far so
we have this updated method but I do
want to give you the warning that it's
what's called a heuristic so because
it's dealing with high-scoring peptides
there's a chance that there's an
initially low scoring peptide that winds
up eventually being the highest scoring
peptide so that eventually would be our
leader but because we cut it in an early
stage because we said it's not in the
top however many n peptides then we
throw it out and so there is a
possibility that we throw out the
correct peptide or what will eventually
become the correct peptide at the
expense of having a quick out quick
method and so for this reason it's it's
a heuristic let's test it though because
remember we're considered we're
considering how well these algorithms
work in practice so here is a
hypothetical spectrum it has ten percent
false and missing masses so I'll
highlight where the false and missing
masses are so here are the false masses
and here the missing masses now we're
not going to know which of these are
false and missing to begin with in
particular we're not going to have the
missing masses present that's the whole
point they're not present in the
experimental spectrum so we'll have this
picture but we won't know which of the
masses it should be green and then so we
say let's run our algorithm let's run
our leaderboard
geurim on this hypothetical data set and
see what it turns out and so it returns
the the correct tire sitting be one
peptide which is where this came from so
we're happy so then we say well maybe
ten percent false and missing masses
maybe that was a little bit optimistic
so let's introduce a slightly noisier
typesetting be one spectrum that has 25%
false and missing masses and again I'll
show you even though we won't know this
I'll show you where the false and
missing masses are so you can believe me
and we say we won't know which masses
are missing and now when we run that
same algorithm on this noisier spectrum
we're going to see that the correct the
algorithm the peptide that it produces
is actually not tire sitting b1 it's
close right but instead of the correct
amino acid here it's been replaced with
an ad so this is bad in this case we
wouldn't be able to reconstruct the
correct peptide